last tuesday the rams were trying to
trade todd gurley that culminated in an
effort on thursday to unload his salary
they ultimately cut him because he had
another 10 million in guaranteed
compensation that vested
as of thursday night and we all knew
that it was coming we'd been talking
about it for months we knew how the
contract was structured the one guy who
didn't apparently was todd gurley peter
he told chris long of the green light
podcast i didn't see it coming
how could he not see it coming now it's
a great contract for him we've talked
about that earlier we talked about it
last week he did not lose 49 million
dollars over five years with the la rams
but with another 10 million becoming
fully guaranteed and the rams unable to
find a trade partner because of that
knee that has deteriorated by all
appearances over the past couple of
years yeah they had to cut him they had
to move on i don't know whether he's
embellishing or whether he was just
oblivious but how could he say that he
didn't see this coming when anyone who
was paying any attention at all knew
that a divorce was inevitable for todd
gurley and the rams unless they worked
out some alternative deal and that
wasn't happening either
mike i think when you play for
sean mcvay
you play for
basically a guy who's pete carroll jr in
terms of don't worry be happy
you know and everything around here is
positive
uh you know
everyone is lovely
it's always a sunny day
and in my opinion that sort of creates
the kind of reaction when something like
this happens
that todd gurley basically now talks
about in other words
if he truly never saw it coming and that
is hard to believe but if he truly never
saw it coming it's because he never got
one single indication of that
from an uber
positive thinking
coach like sean mcvay
and that's an excellent point and you'll
wonder what kind of impact that has over
time on the rest of the locker room
when they see that this guy is always
interacting with everyone in a positive
way
but
there goes todd gurley there goes this
guy they're shopping brandon cooks and
you know and and it doesn't mesh and at
what point do some of these other guys
say does he really mean what he's saying
to me or is this just part of the effort
to get the absolute most out of me until
he's done with me and then when he's
done with me he's just done with me i
thought it was intriguing
the rams had wanted to talk to todd
gurley i thought they wanted to work out
something where they could get him to
stay and gurley wasn't inclined to talk
he said on march 8. it depends on what
the conversation is about i'm more of a
guy where if there ain't nothing to talk
about then there ain't nothing to talk
about but if we got something to talk
about then we can talk coach has my
number so he had like no clue that there
was even anything that was remotely
amiss so maybe you're onto something
they never gave him the vibes that the
rest of us obviously picked up from the
outside but from the inside he felt like
he's still his guy
mike do you remember the game last year
when sean mcvay on the sidelines
took off after john fossil the special
teams coach
it was a game against arizona where john
fossil
called a fake pun and that fake punt got
blown up by the arizona cardinals
and
sean mcvay was furious because he
thought it was a risk that wasn't worth
taking against the defense that that
punt team
had against it and and that was a little
bit of a sign to me
that
sean mcvay says you know what you just
can't trust everybody you know at some
point you have to say hey listen be a
little bit more responsible
and it also makes you wonder you know
underneath the facade great guy nice guy
likes to repeat your name to you when
he's talking to you right he's he's got
all the dale carnegie tricks down pat
but there's a fire just like all the
rest of them peter there is a fire that
is burning below because there is an
intense competitive nature like all
coaches all right
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports